Let's look at adding artificial lights or man-made lights to accommodate night scenarios.
For that, you need to open the file named To-Lighting that's been provided to you.
Before you move on, create a new active container in the scene graph named Lights to keep things tidy.
All the lights you create in this exercise will be part of that container.
By default, when you start a project, the daytime lighting scenario is provided to you.
To set your lighting at night, you first need to change the time of day.
This can be done in the Eye menu in the viewport or in the Ambience panel.
Interestingly, if you go beyond a certain hour of the day, after the sun sets, some aspects of your scene react to that change.
A good example is the headlights and taillights on animated vehicles.
Change the time of day going from day to night to see the cars light up.
However, you do need to place a few active lights in and around the project, which appears rather dark at night.
Let's see what's available.
Go to the Assets library under Lights category.
You'll see many entries, but most are samples of lights with an IES profile.
Essentially, all of those are spotlights.
There are really four options to choose from.
An Omni or Point light that emanates in all directions.
You can control the intensity.
Its attenuation or how far it spreads.
The color temperature.
And whether it casts shadows, among other options.
A spotlight on the other hand is more directional.
It opens up in a cone so that you can control the beam.
But otherwise, has roughly the same parameters as an Omni light.
Try an IES light such as IES 03.
You'll notice it effectively is a spotlight.
It has the same options, except for an IES profile defined in the Lights miscellaneous section.
That profile ensures the light spreads in a particular way, the way the manufacturer intended.
Incidentally, if you need to select a light in the scene, you can do so in the scene graph.
If you wish to select it in the viewport, you may or may not see an icon associated with the light.
If you do not see the icons, press G to display them.
The G key acts as a toggle.
You also have a linear light, or a neon light as it's called, where you can control intensity, length and color, but not attenuation.
Finally, there's also an Area light, and as you define parameters such as length, width and attenuation, you get a light that emanates in a box-like pattern.
This can be used to help with global illumination in difficult spots.
As a side note, night lighting is where Lumen shines, no pun intended.
You can better appreciate the difference between Lumen and Standard modes in night scenes.
In addition to their regular parameters, all light types can be set to activate only at nighttime.
Currently, if you switch back to Day mode, the lights are still active.
But if you select one of them and go to the Miscellaneous section, you can enable the Dusk to Dawn option.
You can do the same with every light you have placed in the scene.
If you try it now, you'll notice that the lights only activate around 7.30 or 8pm.
In addition to standalone lights, there are some assets in the library that have embedded lights in them.
For example, go to Objects -> City -> Street Lights and drag in a street lamp. I'll use this one called Streamlight.
Note in the scene graph that this asset is made of both geometry and a spotlight that you can control and adjust to your liking.
However, not all assets have associated lights.
For example, try this bollard named Galvanic. It's just a simple mesh at this time, but you can help change it a bit.
Try adding a self-illuminated material to the white covers.
If you're using Lumen, the emissive material helps a little bit with the lighting.
You can also add a full-fledged omni light to help illuminate the area around the bollard.
You can then parent the light to the bollard and send the bollard to the user library.
You now have your own assets ready and available.
If you make instances of any light in the scene, you'll be able to change the parameters of one light to update all duplicates.
Keep on experimenting by creating your own light fixtures.
Next, we'll discuss media output.